man wasp also connects directly to
Avengers for these characters are going
to be very important going forward wasp
is a legacy character she's right there
on the cover of Avengers number one
finally every single character from that
first issue of Avengers is here on the
big screen we saw the original wasp a
Janet Van Dyne in a brief flashback in
the first movie and at the end of the
movie we finally saw a new suit and Hank
Pym realizing of course this suit
belongs to his daughter hope it's about
damn time and now an ant-man and wasp we
see her in all her glory watch this
she gets to wear this suit that she's
been coveting her whole life she so
desperately wanted to follow in the
footsteps of her parents who had been
incredible superheroes in their day and
so she's finally doing that oh as this
incredible capability and incredible
drive as a fighter as a scientist to be
this hero she's the toughest one in the
movie she lives to be wasp she lives to
be this superhero man so follow my lead
this film is primarily a fun clever
emotional story of family because of the
quantum realm is where hopes mother
Janet Van Dyne the original wasp had
been lost presumably forever I was in
the quantum realm and I think I saw it
Janet now the mission becomes can they
go down there and bring it back her mom
I'm not giving up this technology gets
into the wrong hands it's just chaos the
stakes are so high we don't have much
time I had a dream the dream what do you
mean the end of everything fun July 6
millions of lives that state deal in
chess effect you know I'm an Avenger now
yet so you've mentioned before the war
ends
you can prepare for what's coming hang
on our smallest hero becomes our biggest
hope hey everybody is Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new ant-man and the wasp
and Avengers for to talk about Kevin
Feige finally confirming oh yeah this
directly leads into Avengers 4 not so
much infinity war so let's break it down
if you're finding me for the first time
there is a new round of that infinity
war blu-ray giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
obviously there's a lot of Avengers
that's being peppered throughout the
summer in addition to Ant Man and the
wasp but just to be clear the plot of
ant-man and the wasp is supposed to be
relatively self-contained with a couple
of things that link it to Avengers 4 so
when Kevin Feige is saying that it
directly ties in with Avengers 4 and
ant-man and the wasp will be very
important not just important but very
important to Avengers 4 he's talking
about some of the tech in some of the
twists that they invoke during the movie
so that other clip where Scott Lang says
I had a vision the end of everything and
then he tells them about Janet Van Dyne
down in the quantum realm that's also
not a reference to the snap sure he's
talking about something else that I'll
explain in a second but just because
infinity war happened and we were all
speculating about what the moments of
crossover would be with that timeline is
that anytime anybody in any other Marvel
property talks about cataclysmic events
people tie that to the end of infinity
war but what Kevin Feige is saying is
that no no this is more Avengers 4 stuff
not so much infinity war stuff so if it
wasn't clear when they pick up it's
before the snap sure but post credit
scene Theory there are two - ant-man and
the wasp post credits scenes make sure
you stay through all the credits because
they're very important I haven't seen
the movie yet but they did confirm that
it's like very very important that you
stay for the post-credits scenes one of
those is probably snap sure related
where one of them maybe the wasp ends up
turning into ashes in front of Scott's
eyes then he goes off to join the
surviving Avengers I wouldn't be
surprised if Hank Pym also turned to
ashes too because Michael Douglas not
super important for what's going on
during Avengers 4 if Scotland or D
understands all the technology that
they're working with it's just the big
thing they had to pay off during ant-man
of the wasp is him being reunited with
his wife Janet van
and it sounds like they're going to be
doing that so once you pay that off
they're free to be turned into ashes
without a lot of consequence the other
thing you may have noticed in this is
they showed a couple more flashback
scenes to og ant-man in the wasp you see
him flying on an ant just like Scott
does in present day during the trailers
so they're just providing a lot of
parody between the modern-day ant-man
and the wasp team-up like oh yeah my
parents did this a long time ago so it's
not like this is the first time ant-man
and wasp have ever teamed up you get a
much better look at Michelle Pfeiffer's
old wasp costume and what looks like the
one that she's wearing when Scott has
the vision of her now this looks like
him just remembering her in the quantum
realm because he has a dream the end of
everything we could probably chalk that
up to suppressed memories from all the
trauma that he was experiencing when he
went out in there the first time like he
probably thought that he was gonna die
after that big speech from Hank Pym you
know I think this regulator's holding do
not screw with the regulator if that
regulator is compromised you would go
subatomic
what does that mean it means that you
would enter a quantum realm what does
that mean it means that you would enter
a reality were all concepts of time and
space become irrelevant
as you shrink for all eternity
everything that you know and love
gone forever cool then they cut it with
a couple scenes of them going into the
quantum realm like oh wow there's a
signal for mom she's alive down in there
so they built the ship you see a bigger
version of one of the ants carrying
luggage through this big portal here it
looks like this is what they use to go
down into the quantum realm with that
ship there been a couple more fight
scenes from the ghosts and there is a
younger version of her that appears
during the trailer and based on a lot of
early reactions from the film which have
all been really positive everybody that
seen the film so far which does not
include me say that it's actually really
good don't talk about ghosts like she is
a traditional Marvel villain so it
sounds like there's some reason for her
to be so twisted in present day because
it sounds like she gets into this
accident gets access to Pym tech and
when they're talking about the end of
everything it's probably just a
weakening of the barrier between
dimensions like the quantum realm is a
different dimension there are beings
that are live down there at the
Micronauts
it sounds like there's some form of
energy some power that if it's allowed
to get out will just completely destroy
all of reality like you see this small
version of an explosion here just
imagine a much larger version of that
where the entire city blows up I've
already done a couple videos about Scott
Lang running around during these
original Avengers scenes where cap is in
his old costume and they're using the
VAR effing technology but there's been
so much talk about why their tech in
ant-man in the wasp is so important from
a plot standpoint during Avengers 4 like
Kevin Feige sneezing they'll be very
important it just kind of low-key
confirms some of the rumors that we've
heard about them going between realities
during Avengers 4 because if they're
going in and out of the quantum realm
different reality where time moves
differently
it sort of them traversing the
multiverse in a small way to make its
many ant-man puns as possible
tic-tac is back on the attack but the
latest synopsis is the Kevin Feige gave
for Avengers 4 during that big
conference a little while ago was as it
Avengers 4 was gonna be all about the
Avengers truly learning to work together
as a superhero team not letting any of
their emotional baggage get in the way
so you can kind of see how they lost to
Thanos during the first Avengers movie
because I think you know positing they
did not work together as a team they
were all separated you had some of them
on Titan with Iron Man's team you had
the others in Wakanda
with black panther in caps team thor was
off doing his own thing for most of the
movie til he came back to Wakanda
they almost fought him I think that's
part of the idea he should have gone for
the head they almost had him win Thor
and most of the Guardians teamed up with
most of the Avengers but you still have
like that whole other separate group
that was on Titan that whole time
then I'll add a couple more links for
the videos about the teasers and the
plot the Kevin Feige has been talking
about recently so just leave all your
video requests in the comments below
new Luke Cage coming up and I'm sure
there'll be more ant-man in the wasp in
the next couple of weeks because the
movie is getting ready to drop
everywhere click here for all that new
behind the scenes and click here for
that Avengers 4 video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]